executive producer of rgg studios and
writer of the Yakuza series Masa Yoshi
yokoyama said during the rgg 2022 Summit
that like a dragon ishin is meant to be
the All-Star Yakuza game in the 20
minutes of Hands-On time ahead with the
game definitely delivered on that
promise but like a dragon Asian doesn't
just feel like simple yuck is a fan
service for what I've played ishin
features enough of a new story and
presents a fresh environment to a
western audience at least that it is
poised to welcome new players to the
massive franchise without completely
alienating them the preview demo played
at the Tokyo game show courtesy of Sega
featured two modes day mode which was a
more explorative and story-centric
introduction to the game's Central Area
Keo and night mode a more action-focused
look at the game's many fighting styles
starting with day mode I spent my first
10 minutes with the game watching a
lengthy cut scene introducing the many
characters of like a dragon Asian it was
certainly a slow start to the Hands-On
demo but bayak is a standards it felt
very apt While most of the series
entries are action Brawlers by
definition the heart and soul of any
Yakuza game is in its story and
characters The Cinematic provided a
glimpse at its stoic protagonist
Sakamoto Ryoma and the many captains of
the Shinsengumi special police force
including the snarly Takeda kenriusai
played by Japanese Superstar Ricky
Takeuchi the rather sneaky Toro which is
the character model tianuz Zao from
Yakuza like a dragon with nobuhiko
yokomato returning as the voice actor
and many more after the boisterous
introductions of the Shinsengumi police
force I was sent loose to explore the
dirt roads of a fictional late feudal
version of Kyoto called Kyo the streets
were heavily populated shop owners
calling your attention other people
walked in chatted with one another and
workers bustled in all their directions
was somewhere to be rgg's talents at
creating a location that feels as alive
as it does tangible was unfold display
this is no surprise considering how well
they've managed to do the same for its
modern day counterparts but translating
into the late 19th century while making
it feel distinct from other Yakuza games
is impressive there were many shops I
wanted to explore side streets to walk
down and buildings to get distracted
with but due to my shorthands on time I
had to resist and instead hurled myself
into patrolling the streets and getting
into fights with many Outlaws roaming
around every corner for returning Yakuza
fans combat will feel familiar giving
the player four fighting styles from the
outset with each one utilizing your two
Primary Weapons a katana and Pistol on
the Fly you can shift fighting styles
which includes dual wielding the blade
and Firearm allowing you to cut enemies
in Rapid succession and follow up with a
shower of bullets or you can just use
your gun for more or distance tax just
the katana for more controlled and
Powerful hits or neither allowing Ryoma
to go full brawler mode with his fists a
distinct difference to the combat from
others titles was the absence of using
items in the environment like a parking
cone or a fan favorite a bicycle instead
the focus was on the weapons you always
have on hand which offered plenty of
variety to fit your playstyle or the
sneer you were in for example one of my
encounters involved two Bandits with
swords while another had a rifle using
the katana was too precise and
methodical which relied on slower Dodges
and stronger hits the gun Katana combo
however allowed Ryoma to perform a
faster Dodge spinning out of the action
and giving me the opportunity to shoot
the rifle Bandit from afar while rapidly
slicing and dicing other foes around me
each style has a special ability that
charges up over time which you can leash
with a Fantastical display of theatrics
one of which can only be compared to a
Kamehameha like beam of energy that
damages multiple enemies at once each
fighting style special move also has a
call out to a series character one of
them being Ichiban kasuga from Yakuza
like a dragon it truly is an All-Star
Yakuza game despite the garish display
of swinging swords and firing off a
pistol combat felt rather wooden and
clunky at first and the uncooperative
and stiff camera movement certainly
didn't make it any easier I often found
myself swinging in the wrong direction
entirely or pulling up my pistol to fire
at nothing due in part to the lack of a
targeting button most woeful of all is
when I Unleashed one of the special
moves it targeted an innocent table with
no enemies in its line of fire as I
crossed more enemy encounters I was able
to adapt a little better which made
things more fluid but not as kinetic as
I'd like sadly I didn't get as much time
exploring night mode which was an even
more action-oriented segment of the demo
however what I saw left me here to spend
more time in it where daytime Keo showed
the hustle and bustle of the city Knight
showed off a side of Keo drenched in
warm Candlelight and the red glow from
lanterns although it was the same area I
explored for both times of day both felt
in a way unrecognizable from one another
due to the distinct mood change equally
I also find it to be the biggest
differention from the modern day Yakuza
games kamurucho at night is crowded and
populated with people to evoke Tokyo's
busy nightlife but in like a dragon
Asian rgg instead presents a more Moody
and dramatic setting where things are
quieter and a little bit more still that
is of course until you run into bandits
in a ballet of Sword swinging and pistol
shooting ensues I'm disappointed I
didn't get more time to explore kyo's
night but the few minutes I had with it
left a strong impression for the most
part my brief Hands-On time with the
game showed the tried and true albeit
stiff combat system scene in other games
it works well enough and there's still
depth to special moves and how the
fighting styles level up that I didn't
get to explore I also saw a window into
ishin's story and characters the
franchise's strongest characteristic but
the thing I'm most eager to see which I
didn't get a good look at with the demo
is how well that signature melodramatic
storytelling as well as the off-the-wall
humor will translate to the feudal
setting of the late 19th century
especially for a western audience feudal
era games are far from uncommon in the
medium today ghost of tsushima sakuro
Neo just to name a few but seldom are
they as narratively dense and character
focused as rgg's games some of which
include hours of cutscenes considering
the Fantastic localization record rgg
and Sega has had specifically with
Yakuza like a dragon and judgment I'm
still hesitant to see if that success
will be the same alongside the modern
day counterparts I'm all also interested
to see how yako yamasan and team will
tell a story from the perspective of a
person of the law Yakuza and the West at
least have featured two protagonists
that are unflinchingly virtuous despite
being involved with criminal backgrounds
this is in contrast to like a dragon
Asian's protagonist who is from the
outset a member of a force meant to
uphold the law I'm far from believing
that everyone who is a part of the
Shinsengumi is as morally balanced it is
an rgg Studio game after all which can
only mean there's going to be melodrama
betrayal and comedic Shenanigans in
store but we'll have to wait to find out
more in February 2023 when the game is
expected to release on PS4 PS5 Xbox One
Xbox series X and S and PC
foreign